hello would welcome to co playing Rixon
40 what 34 okay it's a fairly new
account yet okay never player 2541
okay so we have this g6 line and yeah
this is this i have plate number of
times recently with quite decent results
what did it do night of six seconds I
have never studied and studied this line
in any a big detail so let's see sorry
just canceled probably looks a lot like
a kings in your net with not with the
light squared Bishop traded how to do
this I can also check with the 19 h 6 +
f5 it's hard to not not play with that
five I think you need some kind of space
so do let's go for that hmm it's a
little bit surprising that you will play
with f3 didn't expect this I wonder if I
can play c5 here let's do this try to
keep the queenside closed yeah didn't
want to take it seems so what do I do
here mmm Bishop f 6 205 maybe
let's do it
one thing that's a little bit annoying
is if I take on c1 and Queen takes h6
Hank so in some kids I have to spend a
tempo down but all in all this doesn't
look so bad right or is it such a
terrible Kings Indian yet don't think so
what I think I cannot do is just like
take on d2 and play f45 working side
attack I don't think this is this is
going to work it's very slow ok I think
I have to take with the pawn him taking
them in my night gets traded off really
quickly with 93
I wonder actually I should take now Ruby
7i or care up to be sound okay princess
seven first then I'd be three will
happen then I to 85 and 95 is so this is
really annoying okay let's see if I can
get some sort of counter play Queen 850
a just spotted Knight e5 actually has
the immediate threat of Luke 21 b7
something that I should have seen
earlier of course but didn't he might
have 96 now I can maybe I can take any
form go for some counter play I can't
basically have to take j6 hangs pretty
bad and I I don't want to it I think
after I can take sistex and queen to
take you 726 if i take efore i think you
can take you can take a six and will
probably win immediately and maybe it
doesn't do it I don't know how this
looks pretty awful they're just recap
Justin this is more of a human move and
probably probably correct so yes anyway
i can write age 5 or something
94 2 e 3 I have to try something active
is
maybe you can just play h3h3 night in
three and then just a techadon I have no
square probably probably you can just do
that maybe h3 night f2m to sacrifice on
age three so that i can at least give a
check somewhere at least that's not
immediately meeting me or anything so
night is freaking into evil he keeps us
so what's what's going on this 93 still
doesn't work if I go back well time
morning game night f2 is just like I was
thinking I was saying something about
nine th three that that never worked i
mean i just had a complete Lusa nation
but maybe now he goes back now Queen 84
and he will probably play clean air flow
again
Queenie force is just the same position
that we had earlier no yeah could you
take around 66 between age six comes
okay cannot prevent them from taking on
a six anyway I have any to go for some
kind of come to play Queen to h4 can
even check me and go to h6 down okay Wow
yeah losing one time didn't help check
check black forfeits on time that all
the weird game somehow hey I got so I
got back into it and looked it look
pretty terrible i played this very
nicely always keeping control and
everything yo Knight b6 didn't see that
move Queen a5 it okay but yeah this
maybe I have to stay there i am just
looking look to be eight and go to
defend defense mode the engine doesn't
mind that position all that much ya know
this this GID I'm just in trouble I'm in
their queen a6 was winning as I said
which I didn't do it I can switch the
zone Queen Queen 86 was winning us as I
said but ok he just recaptured Queen d1
back I was expecting Queenie for
actually just getting the same position
that we had before just with those pawn
moves and so did and I will do every
have no idea what I would have done just
looks like and it's bad for black yeah
like this today yeah i mean i was
looking for some counter chances
check the dates for only nothing so what
here Queenie one was winning I can take
with the rock cocaine like this kind of
thing yeah our position for the party
anyway so now III was good hmm okay 24
winning yeah the pawns cannot catch the
pawns okay that was a crapshoot anyway
with no time on the clock yeah so I'm
probably just a little bit worse if I
play not the night over there for some
counter play that never materializes but
play this and just try to hold this call
him didn't didn't see it like that yeah
good play by white though I mean he also
spent a bit of time with more time and
had this time issue as well so it was a
bit scrappy at the end but I want in on
it I think he did a good job them ok
guys thanks for watching